la función f se define de la siguiente
manera
efe dt es igual a menos 2 veces te + 5
cualquier valor que yo usé de entrada
para f lo voy a multiplicar por menos 2
y le voy a sumar 5 cuál es el valor de
entrada para el cual f dt es igual a 13
así que sí efe dt es igual a 13 quiere
decir que esto que está aquí es igual a
13 qué valor de entrada uso en f para
que esta ecuación que está aquí menos
dos temas 5 sea igual a 13 así que lo
que tengo que resolver es esta ecuación
5 es igual a 13 primero voy a restar 5
de ambos lados
porque quiero dejar a la t sola del lado
izquierdo así que 13 menos 5 es 8 de
este lado estos dos se van y tengo menos
2 t es igual a 8 puedo dividir ambos
lados entre menos dos porque quiero
dejar a la t sola así que esto se va y
finalmente tengo que te es igual a 8
dividido entre menos 2 esto es igual a
menos 4 así que si uso menos 4 de
entrada en la función
efe veamos si yo ingreso menos 4 en la
función
efe obtendré de salida 13
qué es lo mismo decir que f de menos 4
es igual a 13 muy bien pero la respuesta
a lo que nos están preguntando es esta
que está aquí el valor de t para que f
dt sea 13 es menos 4